haha the Joe Rogan experience you got in
terms of do you think Ferguson and kabhi
will go down who knows man not a [ __ ]
none of the something happens this
weekend just engage he's a monster just
engage he is a monster he's a monster
he's a terrifying individual he is I
mean in a sport that's violent it's an
inherently violent sport he stands out
as the most violent that's you know
crazy
I mean you watched his knockout of Edson
Barboza
you you watch how that [ __ ]
attacks people he there's a reckless
abandon to his his calculated wildness
that is it's terrifying he's something
special and he's better all the time
the question is how much has he been
training he's taking a fight on very
short notice he's taking the fighting
essentially two weeks notice also it
might be kind of weird to Train
now in these coronavirus times short
training partners I don't know hmm well
ray Longo who I respect very much said
that fighters shouldn't be fighting
because I've already said they shouldn't
be fighting but he said he definitely
felt like it wasn't fair of the fighters
because they they don't have a full camp
they're not gonna be able to show who
they really are a good point it's a
really good point man it's a really good
point this is a you know a wild
situation where there's a guy who's
gonna fight for the interim title he
gets the call let me look that's also
how Nate Diaz beat Conor McGregor in
their first fight remember that that was
11 days out they call Nate Diaz he's
eating tacos [ __ ] trick tequila in
Mexico and probably doing triathlons but
you blow on the side yeah sure
well he's never out of shape really like
out a normal person out of shape like
you or I would get but for just engage
it really depends entirely on how much
time he's been spending in the gym now
he's a man with a plan right he's trying
to be the UFC lightweight champion so
he's probably not getting too out of
shape and he probably knew that in this
case there is a potential that one of
those guys
could drop out because they've already
made that fight four [ __ ] times and
it fell apart so this is the fifth time
it's falling apart which is nuts it's
crazy so it might be the just engage II
knew that this was a possibility that he
could be called in as a replacement he
might be in full camp mode we really
don't know we'd have to talk to him
Conor McGregor knew all along he knew I
called it he's uh he was another one
that I'm sure was probably getting ready
but I'd love to see him fight in 2020
but Conor McGregor vs. Tony Fergus it
would be yeah why didn't that happen you
have to be on standby for last-minute
villains I think there are some people
that they asked to be on standby they
have definitely done that before and
they've asked guys to make wait and
there's a lot of guys that have been
through a full camp and they're paid for
a full camp and they're paid to make
weight this is something that's happened
several times in the UFC's history where
guys show up because they're there to to
fight and step in if something falls
apart especially if you have a guy who
maybe struggles with weight cutting and
you might fall apart and get pulled from
a fight or some of those may be injured
or sick and they're like a little
nervous with this fight we're getting
super fights every week they build into
the dragon island you're gonna
commentate right yeah I'm just a dragon
island I don't know I don't know how
we're gonna do it I don't know how it's
gonna be done is where the track suit
please
[Applause]